We give zero fucks.
Your Ratha drove Joe Rohde.
The experience for people who don't understand what you're talking about here at
[inaudible]
your premise or a big part of it is that there is somewhere around,
what is it,
10,000 years ago,
somewhere around then towards the end of the last ice age,
humanity was probably mostly wiped out or wiped out in a big way.
And we had to rebuild from there
build.
And we,
and I believe that we lost,
uh,
a civilization at that time,
the entire civilization,
which is not being recorded by history,
uh,
and that it went underwater with the rising sea levels.
And what led me to this [inaudible] the reason I became interested in pursuing
that line of inquiry was the Ark of the covenant because it seemed to me,
it seemed to me like a piece of technology that was out of its place in history,
in the way that it was described.
I'm not wishing to put down the spiritual aspects because they are there.
Uh,
but there were definite technological aspects to this device.
And then I had to ask myself,
well,
where could that knowledge have come from?
And through Egypt,
we then start to find that Egypt itself looks back to an older time.
The ancient Egyptians did in regard themselves as the beginning of their story.
They regarded themselves as quite a late point in their story.
And they look back to the time of the gods,
which they called Zep Tepi the first time when there was a golden age.
And they speak,
and there are texts,
the head,
foot building texts,
which speak of the guards living on an island,
a gigantic flood coming.
Most of the guards are killed.
Odd thing to happen to gods.
And then they,
uh,
come and settle in Egypt.
The survivors come and settle in Egypt.
Um,
Egypt is the product of an even far earlier civilization,
but,
but the history of Egypt goes back way,
way further than people think it does.
That's my view.
I support that view.
And I was astonished when you had,
um,
Robert Schoch and John Anthony West,
when they brought their findings about the erosion on the,
the,
the temple of the Sphinx.
Yes.
They brought these findings to these academics and just the,
the tone of their voice,
the way they were approaching the information,
the,
the mocking attitude that they had of it.
Well,
where is the civilization you speak up because they're talking about a
civilization that was possibly what,
10,000 BC or something?
Yeah,
well,
I would put the finger right about 10,500 BC.
What people,
if you don't know the,
the,
the story behind it.
There's water erosion on the edge of the,
uh,
the,
the tempo of the Sphinx has done that could only be attributed to thousands of
years of rainfall.
The last time there was rain fall in the Nile Valley was,
what is it,
the
breakthrough work that John Anthony West and Robert Schoch did?
Did it the initial observation,
um,
what came through John,
who is,
uh,
an astonishingly knowledgeable man about ancient Egypt.
He's not a official Egyptologist,
but he spent his whole life working in ancient Egypt.
And through his research and his background,
he came to,
he came to realize that the erosion patterns on the Sphinx are really odd.
And he then went to shock a Robert Schoch at the University of Boston who is a
geologist and an open minded one.
And he said,
would you come to Egypt with me and give me your geological opinion on this
monument?
So shock went there and,
and it was immediately clear to him that this monument had been subjected to
thousands of years of heavy rainfall at some point in its history.
And that's where the mystery begins because the study of ancient climates is
quite well advanced.
And we know that 5,000 years ago,
four and a half thousand years ago,
when the Sphinx is supposed to have been built,
Egypt was as bone dry as it is today.
And you have to go back some thousands of years before that,
at least to about 9,000 years ago to get the very heavy rainfall that would have
caused the erosion of the Sphinx.
But that only means that the Sphinx was standing there 9,000 years ago to be
rained on.
Uh,
it may be much older than that.
A shock is cautious and he will not,
he will not push the date back beyond what the hard evidence suggests.
He's willing to,
he is what he does except that the Sphinx may well have stood there,
uh,
before the heavy rains began.
But how long before is a,
is a matter that he cannot be certain on.
And that's where,
uh,
Robert Bovard and I were able to take the matter on a little further with the
astronomy of the Giza plateau.
And you find there's this,
just this stunning thing that happens in the sky.
I mean,
this is one of,
one of the,
the great things.
I have some problems with technology,
but I have to say one of the great things about computer technology is the way
that it can speed up access to information in an incredibly efficient way.
And there are computer programs now,
which we'll show you exactly how the stars were positioned at any time in the
last 30,000 years over.
At any point on the earth's surface,
you can literally wind back the ancient skies and see them.
And this skies do change because the earth is the viewing platform from which we
observe the stars.
There's a wobble on the axis of the earth course session.
That's right.
And the wobble takes 20 to 26,000 years to complete a cycle.
So it's a cyclical process.
Eventually the stars will all return to starting point and begin the cycle
again.
And because of that,
we can say that the Sphinx was gazing at his own celestial counterpart,
the Constellation of Leo at dawn on the Spring Equinox in 10,000 BC,
while 90 degrees away,
Jews south or Ryan was lying on the Meridian in exactly the pattern of the
pyramids on the ground.
It doesn't,
John Anthony West go even deeper.
He believes it's like 30,000 BCE.
John John thinks it might be pushed back another processional cycle.
See the we,
we take it back to,
to that 12 and a half thousand years ago.
Uh,
but you would have the same alignments and now they're 26,000 years earlier.
So 38,000 years ago,
you would have the same alignments as you had 12 and a half thousand years.
Doesn't he based it on actual hieroglyphs to depict the inches of the pharaohs?
And absolutely.
Right.
There's the,
and again,
this is the area where the Egyptologists,
the academic Egyptologists are incredibly annoying because they will not listen
to what the ancient Egyptians themselves have to say.
It's as though they,
the academics know more about ancient Egyptian history than the ancient
Egyptians did themselves.
And the ancient Egyptians were really very clear.
They,
they push their history back,
well plus 30,000 years offensive.
Why don't they,
why,
why won't they buy a dryer?
They,
so again,
I wondered that myself.
Uh,
when I first got into this,
I initially couldn't understand it,
but I think,
I think it's a problem with science in general.
Uh,
I think that,
was it a late discovery?
Did they have an established timeline?
They,
I'm ready.
Just the timeline.
The timeline was set literally in stone,
uh,
over the last sort of last 50,
50 years of the 20th century.
I mean really burdened by the beginning of the 20th century,
a timeline had been worked out and by the 1950s it was
very much set.
So they are just not willing to consider any previous day.
There would anything goes the whole timeline out.
And because they've been teaching it for so long,
they're reluctant to open up to new ideas.
But,
uh,
but also they themselves,
I'm,
I'm not suggesting any dishonesty on their part.
They themselves absolutely believe their version of the past.
And in all fairness,
you know,
Robert Shocks,
depiction of the erosion,
there have been dissenters,
and I've read some,
some different people's pavers,
but they seem very logical.
I mean,
I looked at it myself,
I know what water erosion looks like.
Obviously I'm not a geologist,
but when I look at it and you say that that's wind and sand,
and then they showed extreme examples of wind in Santa Rosa.
Well,
it doesn't look the same.
There's,
it looks like there's crevices.
It's been created by water.
It's really obvious.
It really does.
And,
and then there's so much else,
uh,
that,
that adds to that.
I mean there's this thinks is not alone there.
There are other,
whether it's structures out there on the Giza plateau or the ones under deep and
they find ones that are underground that are these old style construction ones
that were built much like this,
the temple,
the Sphinx,
but not like the later stuff.
Then it looks like two different areas of construction.
It does.
It looks like two phases of construction.
One very ancient,
one more recent and they've got muddled up in the academics mind
watching doctor shock.
Try to talk to the Egyptologists about that was,
it was a fascinating thing because the guy got super defensive and he was like,
where?
Where is this civilization you're speaking of this 10,000 Polo?
Quick Glance,
right?
It was like this,
Marx was mark Laner who's an Egyptologist at the Oriental Institute in Chicago
and one of the lead Western archeologists working in Giza,
you know,
and his remark,
which we call it often was,
you know,
show me the pot shirt,
whereas the pot shit from this,
from this lost civilization.
Well,
the argument was at that time that the Sphinx cannot possibly be of that age
because there's nothing else in the world of that age.
How could it just be this one unique thing,
which is 12 and a half thousand years old or maybe older?
Uh,
there's amazing the monument.
How can that alone then?
So show me the pictures of the rest of that civilization.
Well,
some years later those poachers have started to turn up and they've turned up in
Turkey,
uh,
in the form of a Jaguar,
the a gigantic megalithic circle,
uh,
which dates back to precisely 12,000 years ago
and even has carvings of animals that don't exist anywhere near Turkey on the,
on this thing.
And they're trying to attribute it to hunter gatherers,
which is hilarious.
It's really,
it's really hilarious.
The,
these,
these were people who had a,
an organized and systematic,
a civilization,
and it was somehow or another intentionally covered up,
right?
They buried it.
They buried these gigantic,
like 12 foot tall,
beautiful stone carvings were like lizards on them and stuff.
By the way that the ancient Egyptians themselves decommissioned some of their
temples when they knew their system was going down.
They knew it was going down.
The Romans were the end of it for Egypt.
Egypt thrived through the Greek period.
When the Greeks arrived in Egypt,
what happened was the Egyptians colonize the Greek mind and the Greeks became
Egyptians,
but when the Romans took over,
it was a different story.
That's my people.
They fat everywhere still.
We're still,
yeah.
That when the Romans made this alliance with Christianity and the the,
the,
the Christian Church pulled on the Jackboot of Rome.
It was Christians who really wanted to take Egypt apart.
They wanted to destroy everything and the Egyptian priests themselves rather
than let their temples fall into their hands in that way,
they went around and destroyed certain things in the temples and they did so
quite,
quite deliberately to remove that power from the others who were going to come
and take it in.
I sit down,
I've only been to a couple places.
I've been to teach an EATSA.
Yeah.
I've never been to Egypt,
but I've been to a,
at the,
um,
one of the Museum of Fine Arts in Boston had an Egyptian exhibit.
They had all this amazing old shit and the,
it is so hard to wrap your head around even the established timeline of 2,500 BC
when you're looking at the structures,
it's so hard to wrap your head around.
Like when you're looking at a beautiful gold and covered sarcophagus that you
know,
had king tut inside of it.
It's like,
what,
what was that like?
You know,
what kind of a weird alternative way to live.
Did these guys figure out where they [inaudible] ends of years ago figured out
how to build these almost perfect geometric structures of 2 million,
300,000 stones where if you fuck up just a little bit here or there,
by the time you get to the top it's done.
And they're like,
well,
they did screw up a few of them.
There's a few of them.
The lopsided.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But they got them right to who knows who the hell was doing the screw up ones
that could have been imitators hands
were done later.
Uh,
by,
by um,
the copiers.
Yeah.
Basically that's the mystery of Egypt is that that a,
and John West makes this point,
but that it's perfect at the,
and it slowly declines.
This is not what we expect.
We expect to see civilizations slowly rise.
We don't expect to see them perfect,
fully formed at the beginning and then take 3000 years to end.
Right.
Well even when you push back the established timeline and you know,
we,
we can't even wrap our head around a thousand years.
I mean,
a thousand years is very difficult to wrap her head around.
Why do you think it's so difficult for them to embrace the pretty obvious
possibility that things get wiped out?
I mean,
there's the craters all over the moon.
We know there's all sorts of spots all over,
you know,
you'll go drive by the giant crater,
Nevada,
it's a mile wide,
boom,
something hits,
everybody gets fucked.
And I mean that easily could have happened over and over again throughout
history.
And just the s that seems to me to be way more likely then we made it all the
way from caveman to here without a hiccup,
without a single hiccup.
That's crazy.
And this leads,
you know,
this,
this leads to,
it's,
it's an,
it led me to conclude that that academic history,
um,
is part of,
uh,
this sounds a bit paranoid,
but part of an overall system of kind of mind control that that operates.
There are certain things that we're allowed to think and certain parameters that
we are allowed to think within in our society.
And,
and when it comes to the past,
those parameters I set by academics and they'd get so territorial,
it's so defensive when you try to break out of that,
uh,
and,
and suggest other parts.
See,
I thought naively,
when I got into this at first that,
uh,
those who were specialists in this field would welcome some new ideas.
Um,
they might throw them out in the end,
but they would want to see whether there was any merit to the ideas.
And so initially I was really shocked that the attitude is,
oh,
this idea doesn't agree with us.
We are going to destroy this idea in any way we can add.
Not only that we're going to destroy the individuals associated with this idea.
We will attack the man and the idea.
Exactly,
exactly.
And a very dirty tricks kind of way.
It's only later on actually that I came to realize that academic soul treat each
other this way as well.
They're all there.
They're all very at very territorial.
They are all ego driven.
They have their power base in a particular view and they defend that view to
the,
to the death.
Now when you say the doctor's shock is a very conservative,
you're,
you're not joking around about that and I always wonder when I hear some of the
things that he says about other ancient structures,
I was wondering,
wow,
I wonder if he took too much heat from the Sphinx and now he like backs off on
stuff.
He's very,
the Bosnian pyramid and even the Japanese structure.
Yes,
I went there.
I went there with shock.
He's crazy and shock would not,
that's crazy.
He shut when the shark,
a shark would not accept that it was a,
a manmade structure bed.
But I have to say that at that point,
um,
[inaudible] is a very difficult dive.
It's a very difficult diet.
The seas are wild.
There's a huge current flows right in front of the monument and you have to be
an accomplished diver to do any work.
Uh,
shock was on his second open water dive at this point and a on those initial
dives that we did on Yana Goonie.
Um,
he was largely fighting for his life.
You guys are balls.
I love it.
It's very,
yeah.
My wife Santha who's a photographer and I sent this right here with us,
have done um,
uh,
more than 200 plus dives on the Yana Goonie monument.
We went through the process of learning to dive and really getting the skills to
be able to handle that kind of current,
which is literally going to rip your mask off your face and take your regulator
out of your mouth.
Um,
it's,
it's like swimming in a river against the current actually.
So what I would say is that I think shock was a little premature with that
conclusion and I think,
uh,
he,
he's,
I have huge respect for Robert Schoch.
I have huge respect for his openness of mind at his geological acumen,
but it not enough time was spent on the monument to reach that decision.
And it's not just one monument.
It's a whole complex of monuments.
And further north of settles it for me off a Okinawa,
which is about four or 500 miles north of yonder.
Goonie dairy's a majestic stone circle,
110 feet beneath the water.
Which again,
something I've dived on extensively,
which shock has not seen a,
which is there's just no way on earth that that monument could have been two
photos of this online.
Yes,
we do.
We have photos on my words.
What I look for.
Um,
okay.
You go onto www dot.
I'm sure if I just Google it,
go to Graham hancock.com.
Okay.
And then go to gallery.
And then go to underwater.
We have underwater on the gallery
underwater.
Yes.
And in the underwater section you're going to see a stone circle somewhere there
with uh,
with somebody above it holding a video camera.
That's me holding the video camera.
Oh yeah.
And down on the,
down below you is a stone circle and there's probably some more shots of it.
I'm going to just come around and see what you're looking at there.
I was looking at this right here.
Is that okay?
Yeah,
that's the stone circle.
This is the central upright and these are the surrounding uprights that somebody
made that get out of this thing.
This thing is 12 feet high.
Wow.
And it's 110 feet beneath the sea.
That's so cool.
Wow.
That's incredible.
That's amazing.
It's the most extraordinary thing.
Um,
and 110 feet beneath the sea tells us that it was made at least 13,000 years ago
because that's the last time that 110 foot level was above sea level.
So.
Well that makes sense.
With Robert Schoch about these ruins,
the Japanese ruins cause there's one of them that really freaked me out.
I watched a documentary on it where they showed this,
these two monolith,
so we,
we talked earlier,
I described them as pizza boxes there with the giant stone pizza boxes.
There were so perfectly cut and laying right next to each other.
I would just think you would look at that and you'd have to throw everything
else away.
You look at that anyway.
That's not a natural phenomenon.
Somebody,
there's right angles everywhere that sends off.
It does.
I mean
the,
the beauty and the perfection.
The thing is,
is is part of it,
but part of it which needs to be needs to be taken into account.
I can understand why some geologists feel that it must be natural and this is
the,
this is the reason that the stone is a sedimentary stone is laid down in layers
and some of the layers are soft and some of them are hard.
And their argument is that the sea battering against these less selectively
removed the soft layers and left the hardware's producing this step defect.
The problem with that is that if that happened,
then you would expect to see the very large amount of rubble which was created
by removing all these layers.
You would expect to see it lying in a disorganized mass down at the bottom of
the monument,
uh,
which the tea from top to bottom,
the monuments about 70 feet high.
So 70 feet down and all of it's underwater because the,
it's the bottom is about 110 feet below the sea.
So you would expect to find that rubble lying at the base of the monument.
Actually what you do find is a beautiful path cut out of solid rock at the base
of the monument and all the rubble cleared to the side pushed away a forming a
bank,
which is no way on earth that could have been done by nature.
It had to be done by men.
That's what peer,
that's what people do.
They clear away,
rubble,
tidy it up and leave a nice looking site.
And that's what,
that's what is,
that's what is there.
So it's little details like that.
Plus the fact that there isn't just one monument,
there's actually about five,
uh,
along a good four miles of the coast,
makes it impossible for me to accept that it's a natural phenomenon.
And I guess the question comes up when you,
when you talk about ancient monuments are ancient civilizations for 14,000 plus
years ago,
how much really would be left?
It's a long time.
The sole long aren't.
We are to put it in perspective,
the House that we're in and 14,000 years will absolutely not be here.
Now if we leave,
it's going to be completely gone.
There'll be almost no evidence.
The earth will devour these computers.
It will devour the leather and the table and the chairs to rueful cave in and
we'll all go into dirt,
dirt.
We'll fill it over.
Lava will come.
Earthquakes,
we'll shift things.
He'll be gone,
will be forgotten,
forgotten,
forgotten.
Um,
it would be very,
very easy for that to happen.
So then consider the effect of ice,
uh,
considered it.
Consider the fact that,
uh,
during the last ice age,
North America and northern Europe were covered with these gigantic ice caps that
you're talking ice,
which is two to three miles deep.
Your website's getting crushed right now.
Generally do it on your website.
Sorry,
what were up to you?
It's getting smashed.
Could use.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people on that soccer.
Glad to hear it.
Um,
you know,
so,
so I'm sorry,
I lost my thread there.
North America.
So the ice forms on the continental land mass of the u s end of Europe,
it builds up to a depth of two miles and it's in motion.
Consider what's to anything underneath that under two miles of ice.
It's being ground to a powder to a fine powder.
It's like,
uh,
it's like just wiping out,
literally wiping out the past.
Okay.